vulnerability was one of the biggest  tools that helped me break through  some of the ego  you got to tap in and leaning into your  spiritual faculties tapping into it and  not being afraid and for men especially  we have this bravado where we feel like  we can't be vulnerable because we still  all have it insecurity  uh not feeling that you're valued all  these things are all part of it but you  have to let it go because if you don't  let it go it's going to become a big old  bag backpack on your back and it gets  heavier and heavier and heavier and it  breaks you down physically as well as  spiritually  and the more vulnerable i was  the more things became liberating